thank you good evening members members
of the public welcome to this new
municipal year and our meeting of the
northwestern area planning committee
held today wednesday 18th of may 22
there are just a few notices um
which i don't have written down but um
the first is we are being live recorded
and we are also being live streamed
so uh would you please be very careful
about the use of your microphones have
them turned on only when you're speaking
and not when you aren't that would be
very helpful
if you make
if you're making a comment making a
reference to the papers would you please
give reference to um
use a page number or a paragraph number
as a reference
off the top of my head i can't think of
anything else except that the fire exit
should we need it is there and um there
are some other notices on the agenda
if you could please take notice of that
uh next item of businesses apologies for
absence miss bird please
thank you
third item is the minutes of the last
meeting pages 7 to 10 on your papers
can i take those as read please members
is that an okay as read
you haven't read them you have read them
don't worry next point next point uh
does anyone have any points of accuracy
they'd like to raise so councillor
stevens does thank you
thank you chair um on page eight at the
very bottom the last item on page eight
which now isn't moving on my
screen um it refers to flooding here and
certainly we did talk about flooding it
says flooding and surface water concerns
the issue that was really being raised
was about flooding from sea level rise
that's the concern not surface water
flooding and it's really important that
members do understand this that surface
water flooding may be dealt with by a
sud scheme but sea level rises can't be
so that's really what that minute was
about
and in general i would say
those bullet points at the bottom of
page eight do cover the subjects that
were discussed but they don't give the
answers that were given so now if you
want to know what the answers were
you've got to go back to the recording
and i haven't had time to do that before
this meeting so i actually don't
remember one of those answers and i
think that the answers should be given
in minutes um
that is the nature of minutes especially
planning meetings that we give you know
the decisions and the
reasons for them rather than
the whole discussion around it
for lots of reasons so i'm afraid the
answer is yes we do have to go back to
the recording
but i certainly remember that being
discussed the risk of tidal flooding and
that both indeed were an issue surface
and tidal so does everyone else or does
anyone disagree and are you happy to
include that in the minutes
i agree
i remember the discussion around
okay well no one disagrees with that i'm
not surprised because i remember it i
hope that's right um so miss bird um are
you all right to make that amendment
thank you very much okay
so where are we
so next item i think is
disclosure oh no we have to agree them
i'm sorry you're there ahead of me i'm
sorry thank you miss burt um members can
we agree those with that amendment from
council of students can we agree those
by assent
anybody unhappy
no thank you the minutes are agreed by a
cent thank you uh not item four is
disclosure disclosure of interest and i
have to read this sorry to disclose the
existence and nature of any disclosable
pecuniary interests other pecuniary
interests or non-pecuniary interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraphs six
to eight inclusive of the code of
conduct for members and members are
reminded they're also required to
disclose any such interests as soon as
they become aware should the need arise
through the meeting and you take as
councillor fleming
thank you chair a non-pecuniary as a
member of essex county council who are
consultees thank you thank you
anybody else no thank you very much
so item five is the
first planning item of business which is
for birchwood farm cop clerks
we'll have the presentation
sorry council civil
thank you um i just have a query
on the walden house road application
at the last time that came to this
committee uh councillor keys declared a
pecuniary interest and left a meeting
for that item he hasn't done so this
time i just want to know whether the
pecuniary interest has disappeared or
not
it's a fair question
richard no that was for the one down
catch pole line
didn't well i
don't remember and i'm not gonna referee
okay in any case you know the decision
is for the member and
not not
to be honest unless the member in
question which is to raise it and ask to
ask anyone's view
but you have reminded me councillor and
i'm grateful for that we have an update
members which is particularly important
that you have looked at that for the
last item
for hall road because it's a different
recommendation
so
please make sure you've looked at that
before we get there the recommendation
in the main papers i think is actually a
clerical error
so sorry back to business we have
birchwood farm cop clerks i have a
presentation from the planning officer
and then following that we have two
members of the public to speak so
presentation please if we could
um thank you chairman good evening
members
so this is um an application for
the president of a new storage building
or packing or storage of packaging and
equipment for malden oyster company the
birchwood farm battered version clarks
and i just want to firstly draw members
attention to the members update which
recommends a slightly amended version or
wording to condition
um
16
um
which hopefully is it self-explanatory
and also a correction the name of the
applicant is not mr mrs means it's mr
mrs iams
so
this is the application site which which
um in red hatching so you've got virtual
farm existing buildings here but should
road along here in chimney pot lane down
the western boundary the nearest
residential property not associated with
berkeley farm is this property
here
um
again another um
location plan showing location of the
application site the blue line outlining
the other land and buildings associated
with virtual farm
and also shows the
access point from birchwood road down
the bottom there
an aerial view
showing uh again it's the same the same
plan basically
but the the new building will go in this
location here and again it shows
existing buildings and this building
here was approved
in
2019 and but has now
been built
so this is the existing site plan sorry
it's turned around 90 degrees so we've
got birchwood road down this side with
site access the three existing buildings
associated with
um
oyster company other buildings
associated with birchwood farm
and this is a
another building which is not associated
with the oil company um that has
recently been um
completed it was it was going to be for
um for malden brewery but has since
changed to be more more general use and
then um we've got this is the site for
the new building
so that shows the new building in
position
and then we've got elevations of the
proposed building and
a street scene along chimney pot lane um
so you can't really see the new building
because it's
in front of the one of the existing
buildings
um so
oh actually that's what i included on
there so that was that's the elevations
of this building here which is the
newest building on the site and then
these are the elevations of the proposed
building so obviously
very similar in appearance but i'm
smaller
floor plans
it's just a big
open floor space for storage
and some site photos so that's taken
from the newest building i refer to
earlier looking towards
chimney pot lane
um
the new building will go in fox release
position here
and these are photos that photo of
access from birchwood road
and that's the photo of one of the
existing buildings associated with the
oyster company
um and katz fleming also asked for
photos of the other
access to the site from chimney pot lane
existing access
so
um so the application has been assessed
and um
officers can do the development would
benefit the rural economy supporting the
existing modern oyster company which
makes a positive contribution to the
district's economy including tourism
it would not it would have a degree of
adverse impact on the rural character
appearance of site but this impact would
not be significant especially if this
additional landscaping is provided
proposal would be served by adequate
parking and access and will not have an
adverse impact on ecological interests
or the immunity of local residents
having assessed the development it's
considered the economic benefits um
outweigh the limited adverse visual
impacts and it's therefore recommended
that plan permission is granted subject
to conditions as set out in your agenda
papers thank you
thank you
right so now we move to our public
speakers we have an objective first mr
stokes are you here thank you please
come forward take
any seat you feel comfortable with on
the outer ring there
make yourself comfortable please turn
the microphone on and use that
you have
just getting the timer up one week
ladies
please bear with us while we get the
timer up um when we do we will start to
time you when you begin to speak and you
have two minutes precisely excuse me
before i speak can i just question
something on the actual planning
application form itself um which is
which i think is incorrect
i'm not quite sure why that's happening
here and didn't happen with the officers
early but yes just briefly
yeah so just very very briefly on
section 20 which is industrial or
commercial processes and machinery
there's a question which says does this
proposed
this proposal
involve the carrying out of industrial
or commercial activities and processes
and it's been answered no
which seems odd to me because it's
business as an episode i just wanted to
clarify at that point yes thank you
thank you
noted thank you
okay we have our two minute timer and i
am very very precise i'll stop you mid
word i'm afraid if i have to
offer you guys i'll talk quickly i would
like to draw your attention to a nearby
planning application and the reason for
refusal
19-00-241 full
which was a new um
proposal for four-bedroom house adjacent
to syringa cottage on chimney lane
the comments from pearly parish council
were we re recommended refusal of
planning permission for the reasons
given below the proposed running due to
its size and scale would be overly
dominant in the rural streets saying
contrary to policy
of malden district council local
development plan 2014 2029
0.2 such a large property have permitted
remote from community services and
essential support facilities and
inaccessible by a range of transport
will represent an unsustainable form of
development
as such the proposal is contrary to
national planning for policy
uh presumption in favor of sustainable
development and policies s1 and sa to
the local development plan
it was formally refused with the
following
text the proposed development by virtue
of the positioning and scale of the
development would have a detrimental
impact on the semi-rural character and
appearance of the application site and
become a dominating and prominent
feature of the street scene thereby
eroding the character of chimney pot
lane
the proposal was therefore unacceptable
and contrary to policies s1 s8 d1 and h4
of the mold and local development plan
and the guidance contained within the
national planning national planning
policy framework
in summary both pearly parish council
and molden district council have
objected in the recent past to a much
smaller less obtrusive development in
the very near vicinity on chimney lane
either these reasons are still
applicable in which case permission for
the proposal should be similarly refused
or the reasons are no longer applicable
all i'm asking for is consistency thank
you very much thank you
very much
and our second speaker is the applicant
mr eamons emmons
please make please make sure i'm right
i've got it right
okay
same rules we'll have the timers
starting as soon as you begin to speak
and you have two minutes thank you mike
good evening i'm richard eamon's the
moulder oyster company we've made a
planning application for a new building
for the storage of shellfish packaging
on our site at birchwood farm the malden
oyster company has been purifying and
packaging oysters at birchwood farm
since 2003
and we have grown significantly in this
time
in the past year mold and oyster company
has seen unprecedented growth and sales
have doubled there's been an increase in
the demand for shellfish which are now
less readily available from the eu
and the company has benefited from from
an increased market share
the specialist nature of our business
means that there are very few suppliers
of the packaging required and there are
none in the uk
as a result it has to be ordered well in
advance that the existing supply issues
relating to the supply of this packaging
have been compounded by brexit
and this has led to an increase of more
than double the amount of storage we
need
over the last 18 months
this along with the doubling of
production has resulted in the company
running out of space for essential
packaging materials
the proposed building is therefore
essential to the continuation of our
business
and is directly linked to the existing
processing facility on the site at
birchwood therefore it could not be
practically located anywhere else
the design of the building is in keeping
with the existing buildings on site it
has been cited sensitively
in close proximity to the existing
building in order to minimize any impact
on the landscape
whilst achieving most practical sighting
for the business operation additional
planting is proposed which will serve a
minimum impact
there's no material increase in
movements to and from the site and the
heavy goods vehicles will use the access
of birchwood road
we are proud of the name we've built up
over the years
that which bears the name molding within
its brand and if the
and the product is available is
available globally this proposal will
enable us to continue our business
continuity
blimey
thank you you even got the last word
uh right members um i suggest we have a
discussion about this if you have any
questions for the any of the officers um
any comments you wish to make and i hope
that out of that comes a proposal
complete with reasons for whatever um
whatever you are proposing um and we'll
take a debate from there thank you
council for me
thank you chair i just wanted to ask
miss matthews this uh came up at pearly
parish council recently was the
uh use of chimney pot light lane um
hgv usage
um
i just wanted to ask miss matthews
whether it's possible to condition that
hgvs do use the birchwood
farm main entrance and don't actually
use that side access onto chimney pot
because it is
that particular lane is used frequently
by horse riders
ramblers and it is very very narrow
thank you thank you
thank you chairman
um
their
condition like that could be imposed
um
the only issues that i can think of is
that no in terms of enforceability
um
might be
might be difficult um and there's also
sometimes an issue with htvs about is
they hate what are the htvs associated
with virtual farm or are they associated
with
some other use nearby a farm another
farm agricultural htv or
um
or
some delivery driver who's gone the
wrong way um and wouldn't want butch
wood farm um
sort of blamed for htvs that aren't
anything to do with them um another
option i was thinking about after
receiving your email is and i've
done it somewhere else not in not in
this just yet is requiring
signs to be put up um
perhaps at the entrance to chimney pot
lane saying no access for hcv for
birchwood farm
or a sign saying um
this no this is not the access to
virtual farm please please
go a different way um i mean the wording
of the sign or
and the position except the best
position for it could be
discussed um
as part of complying with the condition
but that was one option i was thinking
and on the back of yours i know you
mentioned that you applied for a sign
saying um
no sort of official highway road sign
but there may be some other perhaps less
formal way of doing it um
to discourage um htv drivers even trying
to get down chimney pot lane and and
going the way they should be going
thank you chair can i come back um yeah
no at the urgent urging of the parish
council i have put in a local highways
panel request for a weight restriction
on that road but as uh
panel members know
it's not the fastest process so at some
time in 2030 that might happen
so i think um maybe
could we do an informative um where
i don't know how it would fit with
you just you sort of suggested signs but
i mean without any planning permission
or i don't know
what highway is yeah
finish him the sign wouldn't i wasn't
thinking the sun will be on the highway
and obviously birchwood farm has got um
a
boundary
along here with
um with the with the highway
um so i wasn't thinking of a sign in the
highway or causing issues for highways
um it would be on
birchwood farm land um
i don't know i mean this is nothing i've
discussed with the applicant but on on
this corner here for example there could
be a sign
some sort of sign direct trying to
direct drivers to the main access which
is here and discouraging people trying
to turn up there um it wouldn't be
necessarily um
stop
all incidents occurring but it may help
and may
may help because because one one thing i
did notice was the entrance to
i've got a photo of it
in terms of the sign about where the
entrance is
it's
no not that obvious and i'm not saying
that we need a no they need an enormous
sign um but you don't you don't see the
sign until you get to the entrance by
which time you've already gone past
timley potlane so um
um
but i think there is there is scope
there for for some sign on their
property
to make the access point
to buchwood farm for hcv more obvious
than it than it is now
sorry for jumping in but is there a
similar sign the other side of the
entrance that we can't see on that phone
not that i remember no i think it's just
that absolutely could be
there could be but i think that this is
the sign that you would see the one you
want coming along coming along birchwood
road
so that sign is here so that is the sign
that you would see coming along
birchwood road so a sign on the other
side
probably wouldn't be very help much help
because the htvs probably aren't coming
in from in that direction
i suppose it's an obvious question how
is this in context of the rest of the
site
i mean this is
i mean there's an existing operations on
the site
do i assume i don't know but do i assume
there are existing heavy-duty vehicles
used in the site
it'd be difficult and probably
unreasonable
to then be
unimposing any condition and i'm not
saying you're saying that now because
you're also asking about informative
but just sort of underline a planning
condition that would not be reasonable
in context of that development
it's probably just an informative which
isn't anything that we could enforce
the the applicant is clearly here and
we'll be aware of of the various issues
and being good neighborly and that's
probably the best we can get in that
sense
had this been obviously a
you know a brand new application
nothing there and that's completely
different matter
and then we'll be talking about highways
uh highway safety road audience all
these sorts of matters
fair enough and the applicant did
suggest that they would intend to only
use that
that entrance anyway i have councillors
keys white and morley all in all in a
row counselor keys first please
i'm very against being an ex um orange
operator and also heavily involved with
lorries which i do on the day-to-day
business now
putting weight limits on
these country roads i understand some of
them but i think probably councillor
fleming's very aware that probably 90
percent of farms are all on unsuitable
roads for 44 ton vehicles now 25 years
ago
i run in there when it was a essex
tractor i believe was what it was called
and there was heavy low loaders going in
there which were a lot smaller
than what we'll be running in there with
a few oyster nets and paraphernalia and
i think as the applicant just said there
is no one in the uk doing that
and if you buy an hgv now which is
pretty similar to a car you cannot get
an htv now without satellite navigation
and that will take you the shortest and
the quickest route and these vehicles
coming over from the continent will not
be out to determine
what the weight limit is even if it
sends them down there and with these it
is the
remember his name sorry michael said it
is a hell of a job to enforce that
whether that's one of the council of
maurice skip lori's going down there to
take away some used nets ought to go in
there to pick up some rubbish from
somewhere else you it is a heck of a job
to put that and i i don't support
putting weight limits on these country
roads i'm sorry okay um that
to
to be accurate is isn't related to this
planning application that's related to
an application made by
well pearly
parish council which is yeah i i hear
what you're saying i think you need to
tell your county councillors it's on the
local highways panel
uh thanks for that council mike uh thank
you madam chairman um
i've just been um researching a few
things while i've been here and as far
as i'm aware with weight limits um they
don't apply if it's for access only so
if you're going to access a place it
doesn't you can put whatever weight
limit you like on and it doesn't apply
um
i i what is good i used to get lots of
complaints about lorries running over
the verges and i'm really pleased that
we don't get any more of those i haven't
had any more recently so that's a really
good plus sign
um
the objector um raised the planning
application in 2019 of the land adjacent
to syringes
and i actually looked at that and it was
refused my delegated powers because i
thought i wasn't aware too much of what
it was so it had nothing else of members
and um it was a it refused for a few
reasons one was because it was very
prominent and had a very forward
position in the street scene um and the
syringe i presume it's stringent it
might be another house had permission in
the applicant's ownership had permission
to extend it into a two-story i think so
i'm only just glanced at it and that
wasn't carried out and i think the um
appeal inspector put a weight on that um
so i think there are a few issues white
got refused and they actually mentioned
the brewery and said that the brewery
had a different um planning use and the
only thing i would say although it's
always depressing when you can't get
planning for a small house or a cottage
i know what that's like um
you know
you can always try again um and i think
that what happened to the planning
inspector which is why this would end up
i think being approved
appeal
is because they say the the balance
between harm and benefit and the
benefits the local economy and jobs
etcetera i mean
against a lot of hostility i supported
the brewery and that was a pretty hairy
meeting because we need jobs for our
young people you know they have to get a
job somewhere and so for me i really
sympathize with the applicant i think
they're sorry the objector i think there
are a few problems with their last
application which could have been
addressed um but it's not in our hands
at all but just the differences between
why
the things occurred and also this is a a
committee meeting any planning
application can be called to committee
and ordinary members of the public like
us decide them and for me on the balance
i think the support of a business the
support for jobs is really important and
i think that's why i personally support
this application i do think if
as members we had a world with the
applicants they may consider putting up
a sign i mean i think you can have a
meter square before you need planning
permissions 1.2 meters square can't
remember the exact size um it might help
the drivers might take notice they might
not um but we can certainly try and see
if the applicants can do that so so for
me um i think that i would support this
application um and i'd like to make that
a proposal if i get any seconders
okay well that's the office of
recommendations so that's fine i mean
one thing before i go to you counseling
morning
we can't ask any applicant to have any
control over the highways what happens
on the highway because they don't know
and i hear what you're saying that's
what i'm saying we can't enforce
anything on highways all right but the
absolutely degree he expressed himself
willing to do
yes and i
would like to think if we put an
informative on then then he would do
whatever he could to be
neighborly i also potentially have a
question for mr johnson about weighing
the balance between economy and
other policies but i'm going to go to
council more because he's waited very
patiently for a lot no that's all right
um councillor keys brought up various
points that i was going to make
um
yes some of these businesses that they
do actually use an informative i mean
the jam factory do please use that next
entrance and things like that
but apart from that the way malden's
expanding i think this is going to
happen anyway with um businesses need to
expand to keep up with demand and local
jobs
um
you know i just think that's the way
forward at the moment thank you okay
thank you councillor
thank you chair
uh
i i would have thought the parish
council was probably concerned
about
vehicles coming up chimney pot lane
rather than turning down it
on the way to the so going that way in
terms of that diagram there yeah we it
would be very difficult to stop vehicles
coming that way but i would have thought
that's rather than it vehicles turning
left i would have thought it was the
ones coming up that might have gone in
the in the wrong direction
did the applicant uh think about using a
different area on the site because it's
quite a large site and they seem to have
chosen a location which is right next to
chimney pot lane and
what is the screening that's going to be
put there in terms of making sure it's
not that visible
from the road so
is there an opportunity to explore where
it might go on that site or or is this a
yeah where it's going to be um because
yeah i i can see that there would be a
concern about the street scene on
chimney pot lane it's a rule there when
you've got to those particular location
on on this the map you've gone past the
houses
so you are building
more business and large buildings in a
rural location i can understand what the
officers say in terms of the need for
employment and and we've got to support
that but he's trying to get that balance
right and are we getting the balance
right on this application
thank you all all i can say to that is
we can only look at the application
we've got as i know you i know you know
i'm preaching to the converted here
um could i ask one of your officers
please about the um screening
what to propose or is that to be
submitted for approval
and if it isn't can we make it so
um yeah condition five um asked for
details of heart and soft landscaping to
be approved so it would be the details
of that would be um
dealt with through there but there
perhaps worth mentioning that there is
um an existing hedge along chimney pot
lane
um so obviously it doesn't go across the
access
i don't know whether the photos
yeah so there is there is
there is there is exist some existing
vegetation
um but
there's
certainly um
yeah and there is a condition there to
consider whether then your opportunity
is for enhancing what's there or adding
extra
um along any of the other boundaries
counselors do you want to come back
thank you yes i i think we need to
tighten that condition up completely and
and
there is some kind of stipulation about
you know what a height of the screening
because at the moment that's not
acceptable um the the building can be
far too visible so we we need to ensure
that any conditions are that the
screening is at a certain height because
it is going to impact on the on the
rural location
mrs matthews i'm not sure if we even
wouldn't be out for
um fencing and solid medium clothes you
can specify height but where it's
vegetation
and plants grow and
then it would be very difficult to
require a minimum height of a of a hedge
um
never known that being done and i think
that was for good reason that um it
would be unreasonable and and very
difficult
so again
the
baby's garden village specifying
the type of vegetation and plant and
planting
in the planting of trees rather than
hedges you can um
i'm not familiar with that that
development but
you can
ask for minimum minimum size plants to
be planted and so in some cases you can
ask for perhaps more mature specimens to
be planted than than others so they're
you know make an impact
sooner um but in terms of the long term
requiring a hedge or vegetation to be um
kept at a minimum height um i'm not
aware that that was
um something that we could offer but
maybe mr johnson would no he's shaking
his head so yeah
i think i think there's a general
constraint like within five years we can
try and manage for
those are you know dead dying that sort
of stuff to be replaced
and we could probably find a system on
as is but sort of beyond that on a
longer term because obviously
but it but it's
good i know but there's a difference
between saying planting a hedge and
planting trees
so surely we can stipulate as part of
the conditions that trees are planted
and and mature trees are planted as a
form of screening
what is planted can be
controlled in terms of whether it's
trees or hedges and how big the trees
are and how how dense the hedge planting
is um so that and we can get advice and
we would get advice
on the details that came in from our
tree consultant to make sure that they
were the right
the right species for the site and the
the planting and the maintenance that
they're proposing to do
and was acceptable and and maximized the
the
maximizes the impact or the benefit of
the screening that
planting that was going to be carried
out
um
so we can
planting we sort of make sure that it's
set off and starts well and as much as
mr johnson says is maintained like that
for at least five years but beyond that
then then planning powers do fade away
in terms of
the planting unless the trees are
preserved tpo'd or and then hedges do
have a certain level of protection
through the hedgerows regulation but um
that's what we would be there and
relying on beyond that five year period
so i i would like to put forward a
condition on the recommendation that
trees are planted you know as part of
the the screening
um i remember on on moat lane we had the
situation recently where there was an
orchard printed planted
and that was part of the conditions so
yeah what i'd like to see is as the
conditions obviously leave it to
officers but we see things like
specified oak
yeah
sycamore
willow
birch whatever
but it but it's specified that they are
trees that are planted as a screening
method and that we use traditional
british trees in terms of that
the condition
that
of course if you want a big hedge
quickly you'll it's layla and i here we
can't mean
so right you've had your last goal on
this rally i i've lost track of who was
next but i'll go with the ladies um i
think chancellor white was next but i
just wanted to follow on about the
landscaping i take ms matthew's point
that um you can't specify the height of
the hedge but actually i think usually
what's done is they actually specify the
depth of the planting which is how you
control it i i'm i think that's what
planets do thank you so that's another
way around it is you say we must have a
bundle of planting so many meters depth
anyway just a suggestion but i think the
tree
suggestion works equally well thank you
thank you mom chapman um well i i just
wanted to raise the corporation farm
which is um along the main road
hackman's lane um they've got some
massive buildings there i think plant
pack used them and they've got a
fabulous um laurel hedge now i know the
council for some reason doesn't like
laurel hedges but you cannot see
anything through that edge it must be 20
foot high and it's absolutely brilliant
it screens
every part of that site every part of
the buildings why don't we specify a
laurel hedge like that one then nobody
will see anything all year through
because although the council likes
native trees that's all well and good in
the summer but in the winter they lose
all their leaves so if you really want
the screen go laurel i mean go and have
a look at the one at corporation farm
you know it and you'll see it's huge and
it's brilliant you cannot see through it
so um you know there are some family
connections there on you know and um
so have a look at the hedge and maybe
that's a suggestion um because we want a
really good screen that would be a super
screen all year through okay i think
that yeah i think that might be no
to the applicant um but you know we're
gonna have to leave this delegated to do
for our professional planners to do
something sensible which
i'm more than happy to leave
like a green flow well okay well
it's in consultation with the chair
okay
that's right we have council steven's
channel i thought this would be quite a
quick one councillor stevens not that
i'm blaming you
every right to say thank you chair i was
going to keep quiet until councillor
white just said that i've got i know
what you mean about laurels but i've got
to say it's not just about us looking at
it it's about the creatures and if we're
going to build all over a piece of land
at least let's give back something to
the ecology putting in native species
does that if we're going to specify
something my view is that's what we
should specify thank you
if we if can we have it when we do have
it in consultation with the chairman of
the board members is that a possibility
well anyway the chairman and i'll
consult yeah i'll consult with the water
level consultation
right we do in fact have a proposal and
i can't remember which way around you
you propose the officer's recommendation
council plumbing um can i just confirm
that the informative condition is going
on as well yeah that was my next
question do you accept that informative
as
part and parcel of the recommendation is
that all right with you offices
okay can we get a quick show of hands on
that one please
thank you very much anyone against
abstention councillor siddal abstention
so did you get that miss bird um
abstention council said all the rest of
us were affirmative right
it's purely informative it's not
enforceable but it would be navally if
the applicants would take note of it
yeah we did yes the proposal did
accommodate that into their proposal is
that acceptable miss bird if it isn't
and that's a confirmation it's an
adaption of conditions
okay
right we're done on that one that is
approved with some slight amendments to
the conditions and the informative thank
you
right item six our second planning
application walden cottage 58 walden
house road um again we have
actually just the one speaker this time
i'm following the presentation please
okay thank you chairman um so this is a
an application for a replacement
dwelling
um
with a detached garage landscaping and
also an extension to the garden land at
warden cottage um 58 wooden house road
in great tottenham
so this is a
a plan showing the location of the
application site
um another one of the same basically so
you've got one house road along here and
you've got the existing dwelling in the
southeastern corner which is a bungalow
and but the application site shows the
extent of the
cartilage of the dwelling that is
proposed
um the existing property is about 7.2
meters from the road
existing dwelling bungalow
two bedrooms
and then this is this plan shows the
additional garden land
that is proposed or requested as part of
this replacement dwelling application
and this is a site layout of the
proposed dwelling so two-story dwelling
roughly centrally located detached
garage
in the corner here vehicle access
um approximately middle
of the site along warden house road
in the same position as what's there
elevations
floor plans
four bedrooms
and the roof plan
and this is the proposed garage double
garage
we've got some um street view
um the existing property
one direction than the other
and then we've got some photos these are
the same photos as
from the previous application
i think i understand the
development has progressed beyond what
is visible here
some pictures of the surrounding area
and just for information this is the
previous application was refused which
shows a larger additional site area or
extension garden extension
and it was also for a
larger house
um
that's the floor plans for the refuse
one and this is the permission that was
granted
for um a two-story replacement dwelling
back in
2018
so so compared to the previously refused
application um
the current proposal has gone back more
more like it was originally approved in
2018 certainly in terms of the size and
um design of the dwelling itself
but the garden the extension to the
garden proposed um is still a concern at
offices
and it's cons and our concerns that the
development would harm the current
appearance of the area
and it would be an unnecessary
urbanization of the countryside
and it is less than what was previously
refused but would still result in
demonstrable visual harm and is
recommended for refusal on this basis
thank you
thank you um so our speaker please
that's mr mckinnon who's the agent
please come forward mr mckinnon pick a
chair any chair
i expect you know the rules but i'll say
it again anyway we'll start timing now
two minutes
um in a minute
um and we will time from when you begin
to speak and you've got two minutes
precisely
the application before you is generally
accepted in design and location the
issue at hand is that of an area to the
rear of the application site
the original house currently located on
the application site was within an area
of land greater than within this
application
this land has had uses of community
space for a period of over 70 years
agenda item 321 states the land in
question is agricultural the land has
never been used for agriculture the land
is bare has no ecological value and does
not possibly contribute to the wider
rural area
it's important to know that the existing
houses previously had usage of the land
in question within this application as
amenity space
for reasons unknown to us the extent
planning permission did not include the
full cartilage of the existing dwelling
however our client recently acquired
part of this land within the original
large larger kurdish and we seek to put
this back into its former usage
the air in contention equates to a 16
increase in the extend planning area
however this is still 13.25 percent less
than the original area which was
previously enjoyed as amenity space
the additional area incorporated within
this application does not equate to 100
of the original cartilage as per the
agenda item
the additional landing question lies
directly behind the application property
and if granted permission would not be
visible from walden house road
the mature existing laurel hedge and
fencing to the warden house road
frontage provide natural screening
the only aperture that will allow a view
into the site for the proposed site
entrance being a width of three meters
is blocked by the proposal dwelling
due to the topography none of the
contentious land is visible from any
other aspect
thank you very much perfect timing again
um right members of discussion if
there's anything you
want to ask or discuss like cancer
cancer first
thank you very much from chairman i've
called you certification as you're aware
um i've got a couple of things here
could you explain how the harm is so
sufficient it warrants refusal
please
i have three yeah through your chairman
um
the
garden um extensions generally are you
know
are harmful it's it's trained because
you're changing the character of the
land from um into domestic use with all
the associated
potential domestic paraphernalia and you
know manicured
um
planting and lawn and
potential means of enclosure um
so
yeah and potentially um
buildings as well so it's it's a change
in the character from um
non-residential land um to residential
usage um i think the applicant referred
to it never being agricultural land but
that is the only lawful permitted use of
that land if it's not um
included within the cartilage um if
there's a claim that it's it had it is
cartilage lawfully then there are there
are mechanisms to go through in terms of
making applications for difficult
lawfulness to establish whether that is
actually the case or not and obviously
if it is legally cartilage then um there
wouldn't be an issue with it from the
remaining cartilage but the but the
application as submitted um has has been
assessed is for an extension to to the
cartilage
um
and um
there are there are applications there
have been applications where extensions
of casualties are
potentially more harmful they're they're
more obvious but there would be um and
to talk about protecting the countryside
for its for its own
benefit um and and because you can't
necessarily see it from the road doesn't
this doesn't mean it's not harmful um
in terms of the damage it would cause to
the general character and appearance of
of the area
i'll come back probably a lot of you
would be surprised but i did go to
school
nick's daughter is probably all by one
and when i was at school there was just
grazing on there
now grazing is naturally grass which
this will be turned back into grass now
i i drove down there purposely this
morning on the way home last afternoon
on the way home from work and councillor
sidler back me up on this as you drive
down the hill towards great total school
if you look on the left-hand side
there's all horse paraphernalia brightly
gordly colored jumps and there's a
menage i believe there well
i think that is a lot more exclusive
than a bit of land a good size ride on
mower three or four times up and down it
to turn it back into grass which when i
went to school
a couple of years ago
when the sheep were on there you know it
can't be seen from the road it's going
to be covered well the house in front of
it is going to be
there i'll just find this
we're going against it for turning rough
land or grassland back into grassland i
know it's changing from agricultural to
domestic but
next door field there's a load of goldly
coloured
riding equipment stables fencing that's
no offense to horsey people but
i wouldn't want it in my garden but like
that but
i think this is very strange we're
knocking this little bit of garden
for thing but i will let some of the
others i've got some other if i could
come back a bit thank you i'm sure well
i've got councillors sidle next but i
will just make the observation that
equestrian use isn't agricultural either
right cancer
thank you chair uh
i i can see that this is an improvement
on the previous application that came
forward and is a much better design
house however
i really still don't see the need for
this double gable the double gable which
seems to be proliferating
in great tottenham and wicked bishops
uh is an imposing design and and is not
in the character of walden house road so
the property that has been passed is in
the character of warden house road so i
really don't understand the need to
change it and to change it into this
double gable thing which seems to be
proliferating across the north part of
the district and is not a village style
house
the thing about the i can say councillor
keys point but the thing about the land
is
we don't know it will stay as grass in a
couple of years time
there could be a huge summer house or
something on that which immediately is
encroaching into the countryside that
change of use isn't a change of use
about saying oh someone's going to turn
it into a garden it's change of use
instead in saying someone could put a
structure there someone could build
something there
and immediately that then changes
the
design and the countryside and there's
an intrusion into the countryside as you
come down walden house road which is
what council is keys was describing you
have a view over fields you yeah and the
thing about at the moment it's a tiny
little bungalow they can't really see so
we're going to have a we're going to
have immediately changing that that view
by having this house here
the other concern for me and the the
other concern in terms of horsepower
and jumps is they're temporary they're
not there all the time and they can be
moved and they will be moved around as
as people use that equipment
the other concern i have in terms of
this particular application is is the
garage on the original application there
is no garage the location of the garage
right next to the road is again an
immediate intrusion into the street
scene so if they want to build a garage
i can understand that but not in that
location right by the pavement right by
the street scene you will see a roof
um so it's it's not again something
which is in original to the application
and i don't understand why why they're
wanting to to do do that so it i can see
that on balance it's a better
application however there are lots of
concerns which again you know weren't
there in the original application and i
really don't understand why this is
coming back
thank you um councillor white
uh thank you madam chairman um well
first of all i'd say with with the horse
problem being brightly coloured
hopefully it stays where you put it is
possible to move it but most of us don't
have time to move it and it can look
pretty messy i fully accept that and but
actually when when you look at the site
i think that the
2021
00218 was refused on the delegated
powers um and and this is something
we're we're having a look at
i think they've listened to the previous
objections and they've reduced the size
of the garden which is good and for me
looking at the layout i don't think
you'd be able to get another house now i
think it would be too cramped
um and i actually personally i i like
the design of the house i don't think it
will be intrusive there's already a
house there
um so for me i think he does it like a
countryside design i think it does fit
in with the um the landscape it might be
a little bit taller but the design looks
countryside it's for me it's what you'd
expect to see in the countryside
so i actually don't have a a problem
with it but i think that we go back to
the hedges must be well conditioned
um you know that that there is adequate
screening but but i think they for me
they have removed the concerns about the
garden area being far too large um so i
think this is a much better application
and the house is much better because the
last one was massive and i think this is
much more acceptable so you know well
done on the applicants for trying to
address them even though they might not
please everybody i think they've at
least made an attempt um
to to improve the impact so that's just
my views on it really thank you thank
you
um
out of morgan
uh yeah thank you madam chair um just in
in view of uh council sybil's objectives
with regards to the gables can i just
confirm that actually what we're
discussing here is the change of use of
that bit of land to the north of the
site
to from residential or from agricultural
to residential
um yeah through you chairman the the
application is for a replacement
dwelling and garage landscaping um as
part of that and well as well as an
extension to the garden
that officers are uh have no objection
to
any of it except for the garden
extension so that's why that reasonable
refusal only relates to the garden
extension so your only reason for
refusal at the moment is purely the
change of use
yes yes so previously there were other
concerns in terms of the size of the
house and design and um and the garden
extension but now the other concerns
have been addressed to the the revised
scheme and the remaining concern is the
garden extension and that's what
officers feel would be harmful and so
but the application is for everything
including the gardening system
and could you indulge me because i think
it's going to come up on the next
application as well what exactly
precisely is the definition of
urbanization
and well as as
as officers we would suggest that it's
introducing um
uses and development that you would more
typically find in a
urban area rather than a rural area
and so in this case we've got
a piece of agricultural
rural land
that
they're asking to be able to use as
residential garden land and some of the
concerns about what happens when a piece
of land becomes part of your garden in
terms of how you use it what
um how physical changes you might do to
that piece of land as part of your
garden
um
and that that that introduces an element
of urbanization um because it's
development that isn't
typically rural and
not agricultural it's not field or um
yeah so that's that's what we talk about
um
as urbanization
sorry can i just come back so ah
with a large garden that would be
something you think might be more found
in an urban area rather than rural
it's basically what you're saying
it's not uh
through sherman
having houses with big gardens is
is more typical in the rural area than
in the urban area but it's the it's the
um change of use of this piece of
farmland well agricultural land and
which has a particular character and
appearance which is rural
um to a piece of garden land domestic
garden land which and then its
appearance will
automatically or inevitably change
um and i would talk to we talked you
know people have talked about members
have talked about um domestic
outbuildings i've talked about more
manicured grass and means of enclosure
and things that are more um
character and appearance are different
to how it is at the moment um
and that is what you know
an element of or an example of
urbanization there are no other
examples that we talk about in different
applications but in terms of this one
and that's what we're um meaning when we
talk about urbanization
well thank you for that i'm not entirely
sure i'm much clearer but thank you just
just
just add a point to that there is there
is a general principle
also in terms of these changes of uses
that we do have to consider in our
decision making generally
if precedents are set which
in terms of the local plan
uh on our policies for protecting the
countryside and its intrinsic values
and from office's point of view if we
um
support this scheme on the basis that
exactly can't be seen
it's smaller than it was before
that's probably not as bad
that in itself is set in an undesirable
principle in terms of how we approach
any other similar developments and we
have had many of instances where
um
principles are in a way almost
overturned um to our detriment of
defending that position in some other
applications
um
so
um the obviously the decision must or
the recommendation must stand on its own
and in our view it does
um hence hence what's in front of
members now but also we consider other
applications that may come forward
uh where people can draw examples
so we need to be very mindful about how
we just make decisions like this i think
as as mrs matthews mentioned um
if if the applicants feel that there's
um some
historical legacy or legality about that
land just you know
then there's mechanism that they can go
through
to actually demonstrate that but that's
not what we have in front of us
thank you chairman
that's the students
thank you chair um yes and to to
continue along that theme i agree with
everything that you've just said um well
obviously you're planning on but but i i
would echo what you've just said
um
it's been suggested that it doesn't
matter changing the use because it's not
currently in
it's not currently being used for
agricultural purposes even though it's
defined as agricultural use land and i
think that's a very dangerous precedent
because um if that opens the floodgates
to people saying well i'll change the
use first and then once i've done that
i'll put in my application and people
will have to say yes because i've
already done it and i don't think we
want to go down that route thank you
um
sorry counselor morley i was going to
have no story no no
i've driven past i did struggle to look
in but what actually is the land being
used for at the moment is it sheep or
cattle on there i couldn't really see
i'm not clear if it's
scrub or what but it certainly isn't
part of the adjacent agricultural
obviously
sorry you couldn't put a condition on
there they can't build structures on it
that doesn't work does it is that
possible that would be
to protect
development
residential uh
envelope
um
it would be it would be very awkward i
mean i've thought about that
but they have other issues you know
fence and things of that nature
and types of fencing and how well he's
demarcated and they're getting the
impact of that so there's a number of
things do we then condition the fencing
around it no no
it starts to bring up all these other
questions
and applicants can of course appeal
against conditions so you might find
you're on that hiding to nothing anyway
i mean but it is sort of when you look
at it is
infill in that sort of area there's
there's houses all behind it and upper
there's a tarmac drive to another big
house and
uh it's very difficult you hear what
you're saying you know what i mean but
council of white
is to accuracy is the um
red line around all of the land that the
applicant owns is that what's in their
ownership um or is that just what was in
the previous application because i'm
looking at thinking that wouldn't be big
enough to farm anyway
i don't know how you'd farm cattle or
sheep and he looks tiny because it is
but presumably if it was different
there'd be a blue line as well
um and yeah
this this is the copy of the location
plan that came in with the application
but it doesn't include any blue land so
this suggests that the applicant
um does only own this piece of land
but in response to the question about
it's not very big and you'd only perhaps
get one sheep on it
obviously historically it did form part
of um a bigger field i think council
keys referred to sheep being grazed on
there historically um maybe maybe not
recently
um but you also yeah so it may well have
been
bought and separated in terms of
ownership from the agricultural land of
the wider area behind the property
um
but um
that doesn't mean that
that
no it doesn't put pressure really on
that on the on the council to grant plan
permission for its use
to change its use from what it its
lawful use is as as agricultural land
and land can be in our
class as being agricultural
um
even if it's not actively being used for
agriculture um because i think as i said
perhaps at the beginning um
the only lawful use of that piece of
land would be for agricultural use um so
sometimes we do talk about agricultural
land
being agricultural even though it's not
necessarily being farmed um commercially
um yeah
oh um council is settled
uh yeah i'd like to put forward that we
uh
recommend the officers recommendation to
refuse the application
is that a second dude
okay council fleming
thank you chair i just before we get to
that point i just wanted to ask miss
matthews just to be clear so if the
applicant did put in for a certificate
of lawfulness and that was
uh found to be successful your
objections to this development then fall
away is that correct
that that would that would be correct
because there wouldn't there wouldn't
well there wouldn't need to be a change
of use
proposed as part of the application so
the application would
be um just for a replacement dwelling um
within the existing
cartilage of of the house
comes from oregon
just on that point i think i would be
right if
you would correct me if i'm not that if
they were able to prove ten years uh
well for you some of that that you were
actually the
applying office doesn't have any
discretion at all but has to issue a
certificate of law figures
yes to determine those difficulties
applications are determined on
matters of fact with no planning
judgment or merit involved so if they
are able to demonstrate it um then then
yes the council would have a duty to
issue a certificate but the owners would
be on the applicant to provide the
evidence that it had been like that um
and you do get some cases where
um
some
use has been going on but they're not
able to demonstrate it so they're still
not able to get the certificate but um
but yeah it would be
yeah no matters of fact and no merit
thank you
um interesting that that would leave
them with the fallback position of the
extant permission which
as it happens from a design point of
view i prefer to like councillor but as
we
say there was talk of it being used like
that for 17 years
but you know the point is we we can only
make a judgment on what's before us and
not what we'd like to have before us
um
and i'm not sure that a house that is
significantly larger than the bungalow
wouldn't
benefit from the extra amenity land and
that might outweigh the harm of it
being lifted it is nevertheless we now
we're debating councillor siddal's
proposal for the officer recommendation
it is julie
seconded um does anyone else want to
speak for or against that recommendation
or have we covered that in the
discussion council white
i mean i'd make an alternative proposal
if well the first one fails
if this one fails then obviously that's
that's open to anyone so let's
let's see what we've got if we're ready
to vote so those in favor of councillor
sigls
sorry proposal to accept the officer
recommendation as is duly seconded by
councillor stevens
those in favor please show
those against
abstentions
right did you get that miss bird would
you like me to count i think that was
four four against two three four
oh sorry i was abstaining councillor
fleming is abstaining the proposal and
second is supported and
we're beeping somebody's beeping
oh is it a car
i don't think i don't know what mine
sounds like but i don't think it's near
enough to here
oh
okay one cross look from councillor
falls silent that's what we need right
oh so that being the case um can i have
an alternative i'd like to make a um a
proposal that we um
disagree with the officer's
recommendation i'd like to put forward a
recommendation of approval
with
before you second it i'm afraid council
white has to give her
the reasons i give is there's already a
residential dwelling there the
applicants state they've been using the
garden as residential for an excess of
17 years and i've just googled it on the
map and it looks like garden to me
and i think this is um
a material condition to to approving it
i also think personally it fits in with
street scene i think there's no harm to
the amenities and i think it will
actually be a welcome addition and it's
more attractive than the additional than
the existing building
it's all supposed to i know we have this
this discussion about the word supposed
the other day gosling keys but
it is a point of law that it all has to
come from one person at the same time
but i it
a design that's suitable for the area i
think it fits in with the street scene i
think it's suitable for rural
development
and i think the garden is already in use
for residential purposes and i think the
applica applicant has worked with the
authorities on the previous objections
and i think they've overcome the
previous objections by making the garden
area smaller
is that secondary i'm assuming you're
not seconding no
okay so we have a whole new debate and
councillor siddhl has to stand up first
uh yes thank you chair uh i'd like in
that uh reasons for yeah recommendation
i've not heard one policy quoted um in
terms of our ldp and in terms of any
anything at all uh so i have great
concerns about this and i also have
great concerns as the officers pointed
out in terms of this setting a precedent
rather rural land um yeah we are by
doing this setting a a really really bad
uh situation where other applicants now
can use this against the council and you
know put forward turning agricultural
land into domestic and that's not
acceptable on my view
fair point anybody else
i'll go i'll go with policy s1
um and i'm just trying to work out what
the other ones i can't remember and what
the other ones are what's the one that's
um
a suitable re reuse of land h4
h4
that is the one in the reason
the original reason for refusing s1 and
h4
i would just say we need to be very
mindful about just using policies
because i don't think it's applicable in
cases like that
we are we are looking at land in which
our policies tend to protect
rather than land which may be redundant
or abandoned uh or may not serve a
purpose or may
have resulted in a detrimental impact
upon something the environment people's
livelihoods or whatever we're not
dealing with that in this particular
case here we're dealing with land that
we would normally protect the intrinsic
character and beauty of the countryside
so that's in my view sort of completely
against that and we could fall foul of
that in any other applications in front
of us can i suggest you don't add
anything to the proposal i i think i'll
stick with my original proposal which is
just every application is determined on
its own benefits and in my opinion as
the proposer the um this site already
has residential use and the benefits and
existing use outweigh any harm which
differentiates it between other planning
applications that may come up before the
northwest committee or are determined
under delegated powers
council students
thank you check and i just clarify then
there isn't anything in law i just want
to hear that i'm right here there isn't
anything in law that says if you use
agricultural land for a different
purpose for x number of years that then
it isn't
agricultural land anymore there isn't
that sort of precedence in law is there
yeah
it's the junction
it but it's awful if you can prove it
and you can demonstrate it there's a
there's a fairly high verb
how you do that
um
but you know sometimes people do things
and
they do things on the stealth yeah um
is that almost a sanction that's been
made by particular decisions no one
doesn't know
um
[Music]
don't give a dirty
right moving on well it's gone quiet
again so yeah council stephen sorry
please do continue
to be really really clear how long does
something have to be in a different use
for 10 years 10 years and do we have a
proof that this has been used for more
than 10 years it's demonstrated through
the right so we have the legal processes
right so we have no proof in front of us
only sort of what people remember
and if we go down this route and say oh
just because we think we can remember
but without proof we're going to allow
agricultural end to be converted
as councillor siddal says we're setting
a huge and i think really dangerous
precedent and i don't think we should go
down that route i think that as well
because you know obviously we deal with
awkwardness developments all the time
with respect to the um
on google uh we get google images all
the time
you know google image is a snapshot in
time yeah it doesn't show any continuity
it doesn't show how things change
um it would be pretty
the local authority if we just approve
syndicates of lawfulness because
somebody submitted a google image in a
particular point of time
you know
this is a it's quite a significant area
in terms of law this is an area people
try to circumvent all the time
um so we we have to we deal with these
matters or a particular time and just
taking
or and again with no disrespect making a
decision based on looking at a google
image yeah uh because really it's just
the garden area
to me is very very
very very dangerous will put the cows in
a very difficult position it would even
mean us as an authority if we're making
decisions even on a dedicated purpose we
have to have regards to these decisions
that the council make and committee
okay
council keys
i'll come back
mr johnson i think many of us here sit
on parish councils and we often get them
where the houses have come up for sale
and they've been an alteration
and the council themselves
send google images of a dormer or a
stash window or lots and pieces comes
through and that is what this was taken
xyz
and that's as a parish council we said
well that's how they've proved that this
has been done i can't remember how long
it's been there and they have used
satellite immigrations and google maps
for this
the proposal
um
yeah what i would say is we're not
looking at the
certificate of law uh
a lawful development simply because that
that wouldn't be here anyway and it
wouldn't form part of the planning
permission you know if the applicants
want to put in a certificate of lawful
development then they're absolutely free
to do that but there's no reason why
they would produce any proof here
because that's not what they're asking
for here does that make sense
um so anyone have anything else to say
on the proposal on the table council
morgan well just just to say that um
obviously i'm
being a solicitor myself i'll be right
sort of respect for the world of the law
but
this land a bit of land we're talking
about is agricultural in name only it's
never going to see a plow it's never
going to see cattle on it or anything
else so i think
pragmatism does have a place
thank you yes i mean i must admit i
firmly support the principle
but
not
necessarily in every single case because
i can remember granting
it was about two acres if we can bishops
i didn't in point of fact support that
but i remember that happened at this
committee
uh council students did i see a
tentative plan that
yes it was a bit tentative i think i
know the answer to this
so if we were to approve this and then
the next application comes along and
they want to add a sliver of land that's
currently agricultural are we then bound
to approve it please thank you
i wouldn't say
bound but it certainly would help the
application would it not mr johnson
i mean we would have regard to this
that that's that's that's not
what i could say we wouldn't then sort
of can't blast but we have to have
regard for that yeah
we do have to think that if we um then
you know refused it
i sort of went against uh a decision of
the council because even though it's
opposite it's the decision of the
council
it does it does it does very big
questions about how are we making
decisions you know how we how utilizing
the plant it's it's uh
you know authorities are increasingly
coming under scrutiny by you know
especially on the field about their
understanding and the interpretation of
their own plans and how they use it and
how they demonstrate to one of the wise
decisions that they make
um
that that's
where we all didn't know that but but
that's deeply the case with other
authorities as well so that's why
as officers we have to
you know exercise our position uh in
terms of the local plan and and and
you know any evidence being one that's
through legal processes is clearly
demonstrable
um
and that's not the case here but as you
said i mean that wasn't what the
application was about it's just
responding to the previous reason for
refusal
against a larger than into a slightly
smaller land but the principle the same
exactly the same
yeah sorry so this um slithers of land
have been sold off
for years i'm thinking about brook road
strathearn sold it so they've made all
their gardens
are you saying that's not really lawful
now they can't farmers can't do that or
because i mean that lasted about three
acres i reckon he must have sold i'm
sorry i'm familiar because it's the same
it was before either
yes we're talking about tulsa tonight
yeah
but that doesn't mean the people the
purchasers can use it for whatever they
like
if you see so in this case
i had no idea if they applied for
certificates of lawful use or what they
did or
i have no idea but in in no way limits
the farmers from selling the lack i
agree but it does go
thank you and i think you've just said
it there that people have taken a piece
of agricultural land and they've
purchased it and there's nothing against
that
but then they've put sheds on it and
they've put whatever did you say lawn
mowers or lawnmower houses or something
on it and that's exactly what will
happen if we take land out of
agricultural designation
it will end up getting covered in garden
paraphernalia thank you
that is um
right this is going to be the last go
because we've gone round and round this
project so much thank you for getting it
yeah i mean i i would just say my
proposal still sounds if this we're
talking about putting sheds and having
an issue with garden sheds i think
you're only allowed something like i
don't know is it four square meters
under committed development for a garden
shed whereas if it stays as agricultural
uh it's it's
a really really big building
yeah you can put a really really big
building up under british development if
it's agricultural so you know
every application onto its own i
personally don't have a problem with
this it's up to the other members if
they support me or not but i don't have
a problem with it so
sorry miss matthew sorry i'm sorry i
just wanted to correct possibly um
committed development rights for gardens
outbuildings you can cover 50 of your
garden in buildings
yeah um you can go up to four metres
high as long as you're far enough from
the boundary and so for i don't sure
where four square meters comes from
as long as you're two meters far from
the boundary you can go up to four
meters high with a ridge roof and you
can cover
under committee development you can
cover fifty percent of your currencies
in buildings okay but not you're not in
front of the house but no in in the rear
garden and and the other point i was
going to make if i had the opportunity
um but was the um
and the
reference has been made to a number of
people who bought farmland um and
even this piece of land that they're
looking to um change of use the the
owners would still be able to benefit
from that piece of land they could still
own it they could still benefit from
being able to
look at look over it you know it could
still be
part of their property
but there's this in planning there's
quite a distinct difference between
owning a piece of land i don't know
having and having it rough rough
grassland and actually being within your
curses because once it's within your
cartilage and residential use
cartilage then then you then start
getting these permitted development
rights and you've got a lot more um
rights to do things and change it and
then close it that you wouldn't have if
if it wasn't um residential costly so
that is distinction between perhaps some
of the cases has been referred to and
this where they're actually applied for
it to be resident coaches and once it's
religions closely then you've got a lot
of rights but it doesn't mean that you
can't own land and you can't own land
and some people do have a house and
garden and they own the whole field next
door and they benefit from it because
they can see it and they've got a nice
outlook from their from their property
but it doesn't mean that it's part of
their garden residential garden and it
doesn't mean they can change it but it's
still rural in character and appearance
um
so we're not saying that they the the
the owners or the applicants can't
benefit from this piece of land
as officers were suggesting that they
um it would be harmful if it was allowed
to be residential cartilage um that
sort of make that distinction
yeah well yes because sometimes people
have a thousand days
um
one question this hypothetical piece of
land next to a garden would would it be
agricultural to keep chickens on it or
grow vegetables
is that a gray a grey area or green area
there are there are there are gray areas
um you know when how how much use does
it mean
residential type related use is it
before it starts the material change of
use um
but um
yeah and and it have to be on a
case-by-case basis exactly what had been
done and how it was being used but no
having a few chickens running around on
there with no buildings
that's not residential cartilage but
um right and just thank you and just as
an observation and there's nothing
actually stopping the resident with the
existing size of garden covering fifty
percent of it with four meter high
buildings
there that would be the case thank you
yeah just just bring it all out right i
think we really do
need a vote so we have the proposal to
turn the officer recommendation we have
an approval we have some reasons can we
delegate um conditions to officers
should this
pass
and can we have those in favor please
those against
abstentions that includes maybe this
birding if you can't see me myself and
this is fleming
um
so that is in fact
i am
sorry on the issue of conditions
reference was or a question was made
about removing committed development
rights from this piece of land
i think we decided we could just decided
against that okay just want to be sure
because that is sometimes put on
we did okay thank you members yes that
is um approved subject to the
conditions which will be the standard
ones
probably only the standard ones but that
will be in consultation with myself i'm
just quickly looking through the
consultation responses there are
environment i don't know what they are
um environmental health recommended
conditions highways and recommended
conditions
um
normally have a standard condition about
demolishing the existing house
yeah i'm assuming all the standard
conditions plus anything else you feel
is appropriate and in consultation with
myself okay
thank you very much right moving on we
have
item seven which is
jack's farm crouchman's farm road outing
and we could have the presentation
please
are you off now miss matthews if that's
of course
yes
i wish i could join you
no not really
very happy here thank
you no that's not what i wanted thank
you
and there is a member update on this and
we do have the applicant
thank you chair
uh this is i just draw um
members attention as you said to the uh
members update
also we have um a verbal update langford
and ultim parish council
have submitted their comments in support
of the application
and the environmental health and county
highways have also just to no haven't
raised any objections
um
so the
this is the application site here and
this also forms part of the application
site
here which would be to the south i
believe the site
um
sorry the east of the site
so this uh this is the proposed
extension which is the look this is the
block plan that shows the proposed
extension so this is the existing house
here
again this show this is the
block plan that shows the extension in
relation to the existing barn it has
been proposed that this
building agricultural building existing
is removed
um to offset
uh the the uh the impact by the
extension
so these are your existing floor plans
so currently the application the
existing house has one bedroom one
bathroom and a combined
kitchen and lounge
the elevations of the existing
the floor plans of the
the floor plans of the proposed which
will create an additional two bedrooms
and an ensuite one of the bedrooms
into the proposed elevations
so and this is the street view from um
looking south down crouchman's mum this
is the existing building here and this
large building here you can see is what
was proposed to be removed
um
and again here this is the existing
uh view north down crouchman's farm road
this is the
my the existing property and again the
um large building behind the existing
field property to be removed
and again this is the closer so this
large building here is what was proposed
it's agricultural building not
it was considered the available
extension as a result of its exciting
design scalp and bulk would result in an
overly large dominant in congress
addition to the dwelling that erodes the
existing openness of the site
and
as there have been no changes to the
uh previously refused application this
application is with um concerns haven't
been addressed and therefore this
application is refused thank you chair
thank you um so we have uh speaker
please if you'd like to come forward
take a seat you'll you'll know by now
exactly what i'm going to say next which
two minutes yes please please use your
microphone we have the timer up
make yourself comfortable and begin when
you're ready thank you thank you
i'll start with policy h4 effective use
of land 5.26 the council recognises
extensions to existing buildings can
help secure additional and more
functional housing units to meet present
housing needs
currently our property doesn't function
for our family
our daughter does not have her own room
she sleeps in with us in our only
bedroom she doesn't have space to play
room for toys we have no bath we have no
dining room
making it very hard for me to work from
home comfortably
i also care for my elderly grandmother
who lives next door to us sadly the
extension is as life-changing in the
fact that we would have to move and i
could no longer care for her
the land where the extension will be
placed is concrete and the site has not
been used for agriculture since it was
closed 20 plus years ago by my family
the barn for removal is redundant and
has not been used for the same period of
time and the surrounding land is
unsuitable for agriculture and has
always been wasteland of brambles and
weeds
there would be no loss to agriculture
removing the 56 square meter hay barn
will visually improve the whole site its
metal cladding can be seen as you
approach from the road due to its height
and span and is an eyesore
materials will be reclaimed where
possible as we did with the original
dwelling requiring roof tiles
weatherboard aluminium windows used over
upvc
designed so it's south facing maximizing
the use of light and warmth as the front
is full glass panels and we have found
with our current dwelling the house
heats quickly and minimal heating is
required
the boundary is existing natural hedging
of hawthorne and laurel and we have
added extra thickening screen off from
the road once mature the site will not
be seen at all by the public and the
surrounding land use grasses and
wildflower to sustain wildlife
my husband is a farmer he farms the
field opposite and works a mile and a
half at the road meaning if we can
remain in the village it would be far
more sustainable than to move further
away from his workplace where more
travel would be involved and we would
like to remain in the village where i
was born to raise my family
thank you very much
thank you
ah right members who would like to go
first
council morgan
ah yes sir think about it as you know i
i've called this in um
could i just ask the officer to indulge
me and provide again a photograph of the
actual
um
structure
this
uh i think you go on a bit further
looking at the one at the bottom there
uh i just want to make sure that we're
all clear here that that small
simple
uh
black weatherboard clad
structure is the one that we're
discussing it's it's extensions is one
we're discussing here yes
yes
now i live in um great braxton and i'm
pretty certain that the cricket pavilion
is bigger than that uh that structure
there
and yet noting in your proposed reasons
for refusal
the proposed extension as a result of
its sighting design scale and bulk
would result in an overly large and
incongruous addition
to the dwelling that erodes the existing
openness
of the site
which in conjunction with the change of
use of agricultural land to residential
garden space
would result in a harmful and here we go
suburbanization of the countryside
now
i'm delighted that officers are keen to
make sure that
um we malden and the malden district
stays agreed and pleasant land and as
the representative for
wicked bishops and william i'm
particularly keen that this rural aspect
should stay
but i would urge you to think that we're
not running a theme park here
we're putting together communities where
people are able to look work and earn a
living and it's going to be increasingly
difficult to do that
and i just wonder
whether in the way that you have
described this
the language could be regarded as
pejorative in the extreme i'll just put
that out there to you
um
what i would suggest is you've cited a
number of uh policies s1
etc and i would just
suggest or invite you to agree that if
one because it's essentially a
subjective judgment that you have used
here that if one was to have a different
view as to exactly how this would work
then in fact that development that is
proposed would be perfectly acceptable
under those planning policies that you
have used to refuse it
would you perhaps agree that or thought
this is what
um
obviously each application is taken on
its own merits so whilst in this
position we have come to the conclusion
uh that it isn't acceptable it it would
depend on the area and the location and
the surroundings and the use of the land
of where the development is to be placed
and that's when the assessment would be
made on the impact et cetera in this
particular case the acura it's it's
designated agricultural so a further
residential development is is considered
to urbanize the countryside the
the large building that's to be removed
is currently used in agriculture which
it ties in with the use of the land
and however a residential extension
would not
be agricultural and therefore it would
be urbanizing the land in this case
thank you
um the other policy that the policy h7
for agricultural and uh uh
essential workers uh was that ever a
consideration in when you were thinking
about this application
the actual um
uh
existing property was was developed
under class q which is a prior
notification application um it isn't
assessed entirely against the policies
um
and
therefore um
sorry i forgot where i was going with
this um yeah there therefore the use of
the building was was originally
agriculture which ties in with the use
of the land
right so so but it's now being used by a
hard-working uh family one one being a
farmer who works locally and if he can't
do that that he's not you know he needs
to be nearby for calming and lambing
purposes and and obviously um somebody
else who i think works for for the for
the police and works from home so
what i'm saying to you is that
that would seem to fall into that
particular planning policy and i'm
surprised that that doesn't seem to have
been a consideration at all in your and
you're coming through or arriving at
your decision
well the assessment is based against the
design impact and bulk of the
of of the extension um
the occupiers were not
a consideration of the impact of design
um in in that respect uh if if it was
felt that agricultural tire too the
dwelling would overcome any concerns
raised um
then that could have been done
however
this application i think is is is
dangerous if i mean just respectfully
yes
we're not looking at an agricultural tie
that's the point
okay thank you uh i
the previous application i can
understand the concerns although i i
came to different view the offices this
one i don't understand at all so what
we're saying is we've already got plenty
of permission for a residential unis
unit under class q with no account full
time no issues whatsoever under planning
policy it was allowed
just for correction it's not planned
it's a planning policy yeah it's on the
class queue
legislation yeah
yeah last year so the policies that we
apply are not i'm not relevant yeah okay
but
but i'll change my wording then we
already have an existing residential
dwelling on this land it's a very
unobtrusive single story um black
um wood red tile typical british
countryside design
and behind it is a pretty ugly
old-fashioned looks like asbestos or
concrete roof building which looks very
old and also adjacent the road there's a
falling down building that i'm surprised
is still standing and being farmers i
know what these buildings are like
um and we want to replace the big ugly
barn with a small single that's actually
smaller extension that's smaller than
the agricultural barn um for a family
it's only one bedroom i think this i i
just don't understand this decision and
for me i think we absolutely should
approve this i think it's right for the
family i think it's right for the
countryside and under policy s1 i think
it's actually going to give a a better
effect on the countryside than what is
currently there and and i i'd like to
put forward a proposal that we approve
this application because i think it ties
in with all of our policies it's
allowing a family to stay in the area
and you can't get much smaller or
unobtrusive than either the building
that's there or the extension if it was
a two or three a two-story extension may
you not understand it but it's smaller
than the existing barn it's going to
replace so i i don't quite understand
the the reasoning but then i'm i'm from
the country and i don't see a problem
with it
i'd like to get food
can i just
yes
yeah i mean to actually draw
the um comparison between a
a a building which is you know
designed and is
intrinsic to the countryside even if it
may be dilapidated yeah
with another building which um is not of
the countryside
um
even though it may be smaller maybe
brand new and it sort of looks good
that's actually the wrong comparison
because what we are dealing with is in
terms of policies here and clearly we do
think about you know
how people live their living conditions
and there's there's appropriate policies
for that but the weight in which we as a
local authority have given here is in
terms of protecting the countryside
so it's valid in that particular sense
you know um these are
you know this is this is a countryside
is agricultural buildings which have
through government legislation fairly
recent legislation have you know they've
got the opportunity to to change these
buildings yeah that's what's happened in
here they were able to demonstrate that
and do that what we're now what we're
now doing is we're not adding to that
we're now with it you know with a fairly
extensive extension i mean it's it's
it's it may be smaller than the
agricultural building but when you look
at it in context of the building that's
there at the moment it's quite
substantial
it is a significant extension it can be
it's quite visible from the street in
terms of what it is not in terms of
comparing it with the agricultural
building and i mean that's what we have
to look at and in terms of protecting
our countryside protecting these
environments
though that's that's the balance that we
need to we need to strike when we when
we actually look at this rather than
just oh it looks better than this you
know that sort of thing that's not
really the approach to take
before you come back we do need sorry we
do need clearer reasons for refusal as
part of a wrong for approval for
partnership okay well i haven't overcome
the reason okay well i haven't got the
policies in front of me but for me it's
an effective use of land
it um it it it ties in with the rural
policies to allow rural workers to see i
know it's not going to tie on it but for
me that's still relevant i think it's a
um a welcome improvement to the local
street scene i think it fits in well
with a local street scene and
i mean you know being a country person
who was born in the countryside who's
lived in the district in the countryside
um for us for me i know we'll disagree
but for me as a country person who's
always been in the countryside
we
we welcome these additions and we
welcome these changes you know we we get
told we have to approve big housing
estates but for me as a country person
we like the continuity
and i like design i think it fits in
really well and and and that's why on
the balance of of
of the decision i think the benefit
outweighs the harm to allow a local
family to stay here and it is difficult
in the countryside and i think it ties
in beautifully
do you still second
second that sorry i'm talking to the
counsellor
do you still support that
nelson morgan i was just going to back
up councilwoman's point and perhaps be
more specific i believe it is
sustainable i believe that it
contributes to the policy of prosperous
rural communities and as regarding
divine quality in the built environment
you're actually going to end up with
something that's going to look better
than it probably does at the moment so i
think wholeheartedly that this should be
i've got thank you council fleming
council students
thank
you uh i actually know this site fairly
well because uh when thomas misses his
bus i have to air along here down to
hatfield pavel so um i'm afraid i
disagree with
miss ward's assessment about the scale
and bulk and height
um
i i don't agree with that and uh
following on from others comments i i
just can't see the harm here
thank you
students
i think i was about to say the same
thing really and what swings it for me
is that the barn is going to come down
um
and so it seems to me that there's
there's a direct payoff there and
overall i would say the benefits that
because the barn is coming down i would
say overall the benefit does outweigh
the harm thank you
sorry i've got councillor keys thank you
councillor
um but i'm not entirely sure because i
mean the barn could or couldn't come
back like well but look at the
description of the development it's
change of use of land to residential and
single-story side extension
that's what's in front of us
okay they they may say that they're
pulling down the bomb there's no there's
no obligation to pull down the bond
unless i'm mistaken somewhere of nicola
but but in terms of the
the the the description of the
development it just says the change of
use of land to residential so what way
so what we're looking at here is in
terms of you know
again you know just a residential creep
into the countryside
this is this is effectively what the
position is but it could be conditioned
presumably that the bond must come down
as opposed to the plan is that the bar
will come down well that's not what they
propose so we so we can't we can't
condition that they pull down the bar if
that's not what they propose that's not
what's been accepted
don't worry
um i mean it may be an intention i mean
and um
you know but that's not what that's not
what's in front of us
right i've got council keys and council
but i must
what worries me about this is that it's
come back after refusal without changing
and i'd feel a lot happier about it
if some of those aspects
were changed or had been changed i
should say that's the key we keep on
about um the president's set and council
center and myself had a can you put the
picture of the barn up i know they said
that might not be come down but in our
ward we had a better built barn at
plains road knocked down and three
properties two properties passed
and that was a lot better built than
that there was a brick built structure
well that's certainly not
so i you know if i say the president
said this you know keep on about that
we've had it in great children
thank you so could the officers make it
clear that at the moment the whole of
this plot
is designated as agricultural land is
that correct
there is there is a there is a prior
approval cooper
um
approval which is obviously why they're
living there uh at the moment so there
is
there is that there is our permission
that's how the building is being used
but that relates only to that building
so and any time any cartilage around it
would be strictly speaking tightly
defined okay um yeah in terms of the so
in terms that i can understand the
officers saying that we are changing the
use of the land from agricultural to
residential so that that's again another
precedent that we would be setting by
passing this application uh well well i
would i i and in addition to that i'll
say that this is probably even a worse
situation than the application we
considered before because this concerns
the whole of the site
the entirety of the site
in terms of the balkan design i don't
think it is bulky i don't think we can
define the extension as monkey
in terms and in terms of its impact it's
going to be something small and
weatherboard and not particularly
intrusive however it's it's
it's the fact that you know councillor
thompson's just said this is no
different to what came to us before but
it wasn't delegated last time
um and again what precedent are we
setting
yeah and i can understand the the
applicant and i can understand their
situation however
we have to take into account when we
make this exactly committee pal anning
policy and the effect that it has on the
whole of the district and not just on
this one particular site so yes i can
see that it's uh yeah i can see to me
it's not bulky
uh
it's about that change the site on
plains road was a business site not an
agricultural site so it was designated
as business premises and it was a
brownfield site so it is completely
different to this particular application
we weren't on that application saying
that we were changing our cultural land
to residential we were changing a
business site to a residential site so
again i have this concern about what we
are doing and the decisions that we are
making here tonight that have an effect
on the wider district and other
applications i have every empathy for
the applicants
but that is my concern yeah and i think
it's useful just just just to remind
ourselves of the site we're dealing with
if you want to just just scroll down to
the to the site location plan i mean
it's a
we are talking about a
i mean it's it's it's a fairly
substantial area in a prominent position
where we're changing from effectively
agricultural through residential that's
what we're dealing with
not i actually think this is not a
slither of landing sorry to say that but
you know
i think it's a bit more than a sliver
which is i have
immense sympathy for the applicants
and i have a feeling there's an
application out there somewhere that um
for this side
so i could very likely support but i am
struggling with this one and the bomb
not necessarily going
actually that that's my main problem i
mean it isn't an open site by anybody's
standards
um i agree with council city councillor
civil i really don't think that you know
that success has been bulk and design i
know we normally expect an extension to
be subservient but how do you make an
extension that's subservient to
something that's quite as small as that
um
councilwoman
thank you chad i just want to ask mr
johnson if they they could put in for a
cooper on the barn behind couldn't they
and then what does
no no
the house the the building they're in at
the moment was presumably
allowed by a cooper so the barn behind
that is agricultural so they could go
for a cooper on that as well couldn't
they and then what what does that do to
the whole
site there then
the only thing i could say is that
that's not what's in front of us
and i think that's kind of beer in our
thoughts uh away from the matters at
hand it's almost like saying well if
they can do that and then
by following the regulations the law you
know they get uh
change of use to residential on all
these buildings then why not give it now
that's not what's in front of us that's
not what we're dealing with we need to
just do with what's in front of us if
that particular i mean
i mean it would be very difficult in any
event because there's a lot more given
dilapidated state of that building and
the criteria that needs to be me that
they would have to satisfy in any event
here but but that aside
we just need to focus on again with all
respect here what's in front of us here
and what's in front of us here is the
change of views of the entire site at
this point of time
um
contrary to our planning
policies and that's what's the issue
here
at least if it's the legislation there's
not a lot we can do about that yeah
that's not our policies
sorry councilman
quickie the building if it's to the
north looks like the north on that map
is that the house and is that all garden
the one above it
sorry
here
so this is yeah this is residential uh
and this is residential here and then
the neighboring property here
it's half the time it's probably the one
above it that's all residential
um
so again just to clarify that's just the
extension
we're talking about the entire use of
the sites i mean that's
you know i mean if that that may have
been residential historically but that
that to me is not the issue that that we
have here that site stands on its own if
that's what it's used that's its use
yeah this is a particular use was
protected by policies and it's in a
prominent position
council sorry councillor white could you
just turn your microservice oh sorry
phone off for a second all right
councillor
morgan i think that uh just make the
point that it's being it is being used
as a residential moment that people are
living there there is not going to be
any farming activity going on in that
place it is as you say within the
residential area and what by
allowing this application to go through
you're going to end up with a much uh
pleasanter a nice spot there that you
have at the leverage
and somewhere that brings you
okay i think it's time to go to the vote
it was councillor white's proposal with
uh reasons for overt oh sorry counselor
you're still you're still sick
that's what i thought you meant i
realized i shouldn't have assumed
that some students so did we did we have
the reasons
can you can you just rehearse don't
breathe yeah i sorry and i i think it's
an effective use of land i think it's an
improvement on the street scene i think
that it also affords all the rural
policies that are allowing rural
communities to thrive and expand they
are rural workers i think it fits in
perfectly with our rural area it's small
it's unobtrusive and by the removal of
the dilapidated buildings i really think
it'll improve the countryside so on the
balance
of planning in my opinion as a country
person i think this is a welcome
addition to the countryside
so if you haven't
because while you're then making the
arguments about the the the brutal use
and all the rest of it yeah
that's not what's in front of us this
will be residential there will be no
obligation for them to for example if
there were an application if we're
talking about policy h7 and the google
type this is not that there is no
obligation on them with this this is
just basically okay
okay
yeah okay simply then um effective use
of land
and an improvement on the street scene
that sorry i don't like to be picky but
you have to address everything that's in
these reasons for refute these suggested
reasons for uh and that includes
changing it from
agricultural that yeah the whole site
okay i i think that the um
change of use from agricultural to
residential is like the previous
application it's not big enough to farm
i don't think it's suitable for farming
and i don't agree i i don't think that i
think that the scale massive bulk is
within keeping with the area i don't
think it is obtrusive and
that's what i think to say really okay
there you have it
still duly seconded right
now says no this really is the last
question i think we must have said most
things
council stevens
i would just like to point out that in
amongst the reasons there i heard that
it's going to improve the street scene
and as you've said there's no guarantee
that farm will come down and that's what
would improve the street scene nothing
else really would improve that street
scene we've heard that we can't position
it
and sorry
think that if we can't condition the
barn coming down which would have swung
it for me i think because i think all
the other things that you've said do
have absolute merit
but i am still as i was in the previous
application extremely concerned about
converting things over to
residential domestic use from
agricultural use i think it's dangerous
precedent doesn't matter but it's only a
little pocket of land because that opens
the doors to people saying oh well i'll
just sort of annex this bit and this bit
and this bit and then oh they'll have to
say yes to it i don't think we want to
go down there thank you
my main concern is we might not get what
we think we're getting and no matter how
um
no matter what the integrity of these
applicants you can't speak what's going
to happen 1500 years down the road and
the planning will still apply so
i do need to put this to the vote those
in favor of councillor whites
one two three four those against
that application is passed on
as as discussed and noted
just see the both of these sites already
have residential use on them they're not
virgin agricultural land that's probably
something i should have said earlier you
know it's not like it's a bare feeling
too late i'm afraid
um so thank you and
moving on
we have this sorry can we just confirm
conditions
anything standard plus um delegates
what's already there
well
yes it's all that is all that is given
and if you can find a way get ensuring
we get rid of the bomb
what can you say
okay now we've got item 8 which is land
opposite 34 hall road and again i refuse
i refer you to the update because
there is this
recommendation to refuse which is snucky
sneaker he gets snuck in sneakily um
so i think this might actually be fairly
quick
i'm hoping for the best of you
would you mind doing that honestly
please and to do the um so we are in
fact
recommending that i'll put it since this
is a political thing really local
planning authority resolves the applica
applicant submission is treated as a
request to voluntarily vary the
existence of section 52 is anybody
listening
yeah well
the recommendation is to agree with the
request which was in fact backed up by
legal our legal services lead specialist
legal
so much
and you know a lot about it and it goes
back
it goes back since yeah yeah so it does
go back to 1984 and uh this bit of land
was originally
gravel pits and
the
back in 1984 the there was a
section 52 which was the law at the time
uh which is now out of date in terms of
in terms of the law
and as part of the agreement back in the
1980s
the uh
playing field cricket pitch was given to
the village in return for granting six
houses to be built on this particular
land even though there was a section 52
protecting that land so there was a that
precedent was set uh that went on for an
awful long time several people owned the
land and tried to appeal it and and went
through a long-winded process in 2017
outline planning commission was given
for this particular site
which uh was one appeal but then we had
this still the section 52 which when
went to a land tribunal where nobody
from the it's apart from the legal
representation from the council was
allowed to go talk nobody from the
village was allowed to go and talk and
at that land tribunal the judge decided
that it was right to pass a planning
application however the section 52 still
applies to this particular bit of land
and the landowner is that is now asking
for that particular bit of section 52 on
this parcel of land to be removed but in
the remaining parcels of land that they
will still be protected and that's the
crucial element of this particular thing
that we re we still have the legal
protection on those other parcels of
land
including the cricket pits and the land
that that goes that bounds is a boundary
to this in terms of creating a boundary
to
you know
a buffer so that you know things
hopefully could never be bought who
knows um but yeah that that was the
intention for this piece of land
exactly
and 30 years later
so hopefully you know if
we i don't think we have really a choice
in this um yeah it's my opinion i mean i
think one of the key things are
obviously it would need to go through
its due process yeah um if it were um in
with this part of the land it's quite
clear
i said planning permission on appeal and
all the rest of it the land tribunal
we had a legal opinion when this came to
to to members back in 20 2018
um
the lie of the lands has changed in
terms of development and that sort of
thing and whether the section 52
um
[Music]
intentions
have any place in today's society for
you know
developing land and and the need for
housing and that and that sort of thing
yeah um but it as counsel said it just
relates to the application site and not
beyond that this is really a formality
because
um
they
they have
um approval through the land tribunal
but this documentation
relates to the appeal scheme
so really as i sort of said in the in in
the report here it's really a change of
the reference
yeah um they can still go ahead and
build it if they want but you know
legally when you're doing whatever you
do uh as a house builder is to get all
your papers in order and that that piece
of paper is
is not in order in terms of what they
can build on the site and and the and
the legality so
that that that's what's in front of us
and it's not
it's it's an agreement which is why as
you said it seems pretty strange it's a
voluntary agreement to say okay we can
change it but we
but within that is the assurances yeah
that it will
remain as per the land tribunal decision
i was about to ask for a second to
agreeing that i think is that what you
were going to do
oh well if you have a piece to say
please say i i think i think the other
thing that we need to be concerned about
this or all we need to be where about
this is if we do refuse it then we're
going to go down some illegal prices
which is going to cost us money
and i don't think we need to be doing
that at this time
so that's the other reason i think yeah
this is important that we take
the right decision at this particular
time in that case i'm looking for a
proposal would
somebody well let's let's have a
proposal then you can debate the
proposal you don't have to debate it in
advance
oh counselor you've
fully grasped the subject so i i would
like to afford a recommendation that we
uh
agree to the requests it is really what
here
council is seconding that castle right
yeah i agree
what i wanted to say is that we have
this massive fight to approve
individual houses and yet when it comes
to something that's really really
controversial we've been fighting for
donkeys years it's the same old thing
that we have to approve it because of
the decisions made up in the legal
decisions and
i i just find this really difficult
on a personal level which is why we're
members because it's our personal
opinions in line with legislation and
yes we have to agree i accept that but
it doesn't mean so i have to like it
um whereas the previous application i
had no objections to this one because of
the way it was set up i do have
objections to but like between a rock
and a hard place we've got nowhere to go
we have to agree the recommendation
sadly
this isn't anything to do with planners
or planning this is to do with the
landfill
and but it visibility for the planet
um
council key second did that we have a
formal proposal julie seconded those in
favor pause that please subscribe
yeah
so um
the other thing i would just say is that
our part has planned in this process
it's only because the documentation is a
planning documentation
and it's us editing it
yeah the land tribunal can't edit the
document
no i really accept that uh say but it's
just it's just really frustrating you
know but
sorry
moving on item i think it was nine is
any other items of business the chairman
considers are urgent you'll be grateful
to hear there are none and i therefore
with thanks to members and officers
and anyone else is still there um close
the meeting at nine
thirty eight and i'd like to thank the
chairman for indulging us in our our
talking so thank you very much
you